i mean they're literally two of the best
nba players to ever play the game
two goats lebron james versus kevin
durant who has the better highlights
today's categories
are hang time show time
one hand which is our surprisingly great
category viral moment
and rival moment this episode of
one-on-one is presented by state farm
when it comes to insurance
you can get the personalized service of
a local agent for a surprisingly great
rate with state farm
i just i can't wait for this one this
one's going to be great to help me get
the job done i got to bring in my
co-host my partner in crime
cue rich what's up baby yes sir ready to
get it done man these two are the greats
right here
guys a two-time nba all-star ncaa
champion olympic gold medalist the list
goes on and on
carlos boozer what's up baby
hold that what up q what's up fellas
y'all good
hey man i'm great i'm glad to have you
on the show bro how are you feeling to
be here
good to be here some good highlights man
these two got some of them
i just hope i ain't on none of them you
know what i mean but they got a lot of
hot
out hey nobody just stay for one-on-one
bro you might be in all of them bro i
don't know
here we go first clip lebron with the
monster valley
or jason
like they do on 2k when you get
yeah the fact that we're starting with
this one it's just i'm getting
i'm getting excited already because this
one right here this way
on the hang time part brian had a lot of
hang time on that one
he got a technical on that like wait a
minute no
did he did he really know what i gave
him
cause he stared at him oh that's
terrible that's crazy
all right let's move on to the next one
we have kd
putting someone on a poster
and i believe that someone is oh
they put their hands on you
i like that yeah that's tough i like
roy's reaction because it was just kind
of like a respect thing like he just
left the whole thing just like
all right all right oh yeah you know he
got body the thing about kd is he makes
it look so
easy though you make it look so
emphasized
right there he didn't even react a lot
of kawhi leonard
this is gonna be a tough one this is
going to be a tough one
i'm gonna put it to you like this i i
think the lebron was gonna get a lot of
love because it's an alley-oop
but to me because it's all jt was a
guard
you know ah it looked good but i like
the kd one because it's on a seven
footer like i like that he went right by
pg and jump right over here
and i ain't like hypocrite that much
anyway when i play so i'm wrong with
that
i love the honesty i love the honesty
hey hey look i gotta give it a buck man
i'm going with that one yo
all but i genuinely have to disagree
i have to go with my man lebron on this
one also shout out to jason terry uh he
was on our show rocking out with us like
cube rich always says i hate it had to
be him but uh
you know lebron just this lebron like
what are we even talking about here guys
i think this is a clear win for lebron
this man floated in the air grabbed the
oop
and just did him dirty and just walked
away and it's great i can't
i think it's i mean kd did it i'm not
i'm not going against katie at all but
come on this is the goat right here
doing what the goat does
i'm going with lebron i'm going lebron
this is a hard one right here
but when you look at the plays and you
look at the two of them
i kind of have to i only have to half
agree because i'm not going to go as far
as booze would i have no problems with
big boy
i do have to agree with him
i do have to agree that
kd's play was more impressive because he
went over the 7-2
guy who i believe at some point led the
league in blocks and he was known for
dependent defending the rim
and when you look at lebron going over
jt
money although it was a crazy highlight
it was
it was a dope play when you start from
the show still to the flip back to the
boom bang to the lobby
you know and then he stood over but it's
like when you look at the difference in
size
lebron's supposed to do him like that
right if he's here to jump
and and and kd that that kd hibbert
that's like he slayed the giants so i
gotta go that's actually
a pretty solid point after you saying
that it does
change my perspective a little bit i'm
not going to change my vote but my
perspective
is a little different now uh which means
that kd wins round one
kd is taking a hang time category let's
clap it up for kd let's clap it up okay
one time all right our next category is
called
showtime uh i don't know what this is
let's check it out lebron's first up
let's see what happens all right this
clip
lebron homage to the laker great
kobe bryant that was a filthy reverse
yeah i like that yeah
yeah i like that especially at the aac
doing that you know what i mean like
he's 17 years then doing this
that's that's filthy like like you said
to to be at this point in this man's
career and he's still
doing he's doing this the slow-mo look
make him look even more fire too by the
way
oh yeah yeah
let's go to kd's clip let's see what
he's got
all right so katie's clip oh my goodness
oh he got lebron's ankles i like that
oh nobody's safe
oh they put him oh see now see this is
this is
oh my goodness oh
man i forgot about that
i totally forgot about this too and this
had to be the finals that's
tough it was definitely the finals and
you got to close out hard because he's
such a good shooter
you got to close out hard
that's tough yeah this is a no-brainer
though q this is a no-brainer by the way
i'm going with kd i just because of the
way the whole play broke down and the
setting of it like
the skip has and it's ended and this is
kd versus brian braun versus kd
all day on the one-on-one show and
they're actually going to show them
one-on-one
on the closeout and this will happen i
gotta go with a.d
yeah we didn't give you much of a choice
i don't think we gave ourselves
much of a choice on this one i'm
honestly like
i love to go against the grain and keep
the show interesting
on this one right here this is
all the way home q is it a sweet did we
just get a sweet
i'm i'm not i'm not about to go against
the grain like you man you know as soon
as you see the video with this
kb lebron in the video it's kind of like
there you go that's a clean
sweep for my man kd which puts him up
to 2-0 right now in the one-on-one
battle against lebron this is crazy i
would have never guessed
katie would have a 2-0 lead in the
one-on-one battle
our next category is called one hand
which is our surprisingly great category
that's when a place starts off looking
not so great but then
ends up being surprisingly great let's
check it out
one hand on them game winner against
toronto
oh my god that was that was that's it
cute that's
tough who even can go to that move
i'm about to say that's like in the
corridor into the shot clock shot not a
game
for the game
yeah that was clean for the game winner
too and what the poise he got look at
this
one leg face
[Music]
that was picture perfect too
[Applause]
that's that's what this coach what you
want me to do coach what you mean
he's had it from out of bounds coach
said coach ben i didn't say nothing
look at me crazy yeah
that's crazy yeah
let's check out katie's clip uh oh
playoff game winner
taking on the mavs oh
the contested shot i remember that
it don't come close though
it don't come close though it don't i
like it though you got a lot of game
winners
and that's that's solid but the one
legged going out of bounds though
off the glass and you got a little bit
of the fact that they are
also down one point that's the thing you
know
you know ties yeah this one was if i
missed this we lose
and that's tricky yeah yeah
dude that's tricks on them now
yeah i know they just play d
[Music]
q i think we're gonna start with you on
this one bro i'm still
going with this lebron play man and the
fact let me tell you what else the other
thing that
that seals the deal for me he left
triple zeros on the clock it was no
nothing behind this this is i'm walking
off yeah pretty one hand like
this is for real you never see this like
the shot that kd hit as tough as it was
as hard as it is we've seen
different guys get today's flight turn
and make a shot i
i can't remember seeing anybody a
superstar anybody
win the game like that
[Music]
one leg and like his body the way his
whole body was facing in the wrong
direction
he shot that thing like this like
effortlessly
and it was pretty it was like it was
supposed to be some ugly terrible stuff
it was pretty look at this
hand like where's he like
[Applause]
there's no question there's no question
that even though i love the kd shot
down one it's a little it's a hell of a
bouncer off off the rim
uh to get the dub but this right you'll
never see this again
so y'all both going with lebron 100
100 you know what not that my vote
matters i actually was gonna go with kd
though
i don't i can't recall seeing that
lebron shot for a game winner
i've never seen that shot before and i
might not see it again
i can't disagree with y'all i can't
disagree you know i can't disagree with
john this one you're right you're right
you're right the problem with this one
is to take that shot to have the poison
even take that shot bro that's one of
them like a big like who like you know
it's always that one dude in high school
who
already built and looked like a pro and
he everything he did yeah
lebron gets the one hand surprisingly
great category
w which makes the match up right now
two to one kd still up and it's time to
move on to the next round
the next category it's called viral
moment this has got to be one of the
best categories i can't both have a lot
of goals look at it
we know that uh-huh yeah
yeah oh i remember that yeah i remember
that
i remember that my goodness i mean
lebron has
unlimited amounts one still was in here
like
15 or 16 though yeah wasn't it
that's
supposed to be up there like look at
this
and by the way them shoes was hard boy
the nike shoe bar super hard
to join look how he boys afterwards
look like the hulk of somebody oh
that's me right there that's me
that's the soap come on dog yeah yeah
that's definitely assault look at jr
yeah yeah way too much money to be that
angry why are you that angry at them
at night come on that ain't right oh my
goodness
yeah this is gonna be a hard one to beat
kd i don't know
kd let's see
oh oh my god big throw down on hayward
from here
[Applause]
that was me that was ugh that was me too
that's crazy this is this is tough
oh my god yo this is one of those types
of dunks where
if that if that happens to me i'm gonna
just call a timeout
i love this team i used to love watching
of yeah right there that is the most
he's like yeah he got me
he's like he got me now he's got more
salt
that's tough guys whoever picked these
two these two plays out great job this
is definitely
tough i think i'm going with kd man i
think i am even though i love the i love
the lebron one
i love the lebron but i feel like
brennan's a little more of
a of a rim protector than murky chase to
me plus
mainly because what my man q pointed out
brendan's reaction can we get brendan's
reaction on here
that's that's the main this was like
right there
he got me yeah i gotta give it to lebron
bro
this is the goat man this is ridiculous
i just it
[Music]
he just makes a way out of no way like i
gotta give it to him now look
i will say this this is not who the best
player is this is we're talking
specifically about best highlight and i
will say
the end of that kd slam was wild
like that just that that was a solid
highlight but i'm going with my man
lebron on this
looking at the scope is we asking the
biggest viral moment i'm gonna have to
say is kd
because this is in the western
conference finals
yeah he got the end one he got the n1 so
he got the whistle where you get the
the constant replays on national tv so
if you didn't catch it right away
you getting a constant replay boom boom
boom you getting every angle that we
getting while they said that you said a
great point
and lebron's was crazy but it wasn't
even in the playoffs it was just a
regular game in the season
and it was absolutely bonkers but look
he knocked this man down
he went up an extra little bit when he
hit him and then flushed it fell
down guys running in then you get to see
brendan face at the end
and and like right here like look at the
stair dance like
this right here the face right there
he's still looking at him he's still
looking at them
all i know is that it's the western
conference finals
everybody like this is the whole rest of
the nba is tweeting this and between
this
that that lebron game have to got half
the league feels playing
nobody ain't playing with four teams in
the league right now and it's only one
game a night the other teams are
watching so
everybody is retweeting and reacting and
going crazy and losing their mind on
social media
for this play because it's the final the
western conference final so
i i gotta say the bigger viral moment
was kd
kd wins the viral moment category i
gotta give him his flowers let's clap it
up for kd
which puts kd out of three
to one lead in the one-on-one match-up
versus lebron
we got one more category left y'all one
more
i'm i'm curious to see who takes the w i
don't know
name of this last category is called
rival
moment rifle moment okay
[Music]
this might be his best defensive play of
all time because it led to a
championship you know what to me
like and then you think about how he
jumped he jumped so we have both sides
of the rim covered
if you come on the on the regular side i
guess
i got you yeah 73 wins
not tonight
not up in here yeah for real
that's that's a legendary iconic moment
right there the deep
three hand in his face
look at this
[Music]
that's so gangster that's still the game
right there
that's tough
like the equalizer
was a handful of sunflower seeds
you're not wrong with this one bro
that's cold buddy right dude look at
your boy your partner's gasped like he
just got the number
one over there
he like yeah y'all fellas already know i
had to represent for the crew
oh man he's a bad boy you gotta be a bad
boy to do something like that bad
but i'm going with brian though man this
this play you know what i mean
like dethroning the golden state
warriors
73 and 19. this was an iconic moment
where he gets back
i mean obviously there might have been
some more chances for them to win the
game but he stopped that's like a
statement in the final like we're going
to win this finals no matter what
brian and did you see where brown
started from he started from the
opposite three-point corner
spread it all the way down and got the
block that it was amazing
his effort his hustle um i'll give it to
brown on this one all day
i'm just gonna have to simply agree i i
i love to to
to keep it interesting but this right
here is greatness man
this this block right here changed my
life when i watched this i said
what was that it's it's just great this
man
it is incredible defense and in one of
the most incredible moments the timing
of it just changed
everything for that team so yeah i got
to give it to lebron q
please tell me you're going with lebron
this one
listen i am i'm going with lebron i feel
i
agree with booze this was this was like
uh
when you see lebron going into the hall
of fame this play
is one of the plays for forever like it
will be
symbolic of one of his greatest moments
of his career
and how special this was like you said
against a 73-9
win team and this was the only win in
cleveland history the
finals championship so i mean the the
kd play was was was excellent and it was
it was it was definitely gangster and it
gave you all of the
the vibes you was looking for but i
think this play is like one of those
legendary play like when you see uh the
mj shot on elo and those type like this
is
this is like lebron's one of his
versions of those type of moments so i
think that this definitely wins this
category lebron clean
sweep i think no brainer win lebron gets
the w
on the rival moment category which makes
the end of this very clear kd
wins over lebron james three to two in
our 101 battle matchup remember
this is just specifically highlights not
who the best player
is and my man kd came out strong
from the jump and won the entire thing
big congratulations to my man kd for
winning a one-on-one battle can we clap
it up one more time
take it down and the one-on-one battle
carlos boozer thank you so much for
joining us bro
how are you feeling wow man all right
well once again carlos thank you so much
for joining us cute
you're always a pleasure everybody
watching until next time thank you for
watching 101 presented by state farmers
surprising great rates
peace out this episode was brought to
you by state farm
like a good neighbor state farm is there
you